[Music]
in all some porn news yes oh you know
those real estate agents yeah
it was this education site that taught
you about like feelings and stuff and
like why people are the way they are
like relationships and stuff white
people but there's this one part where
they started talking about the damaging
effects of porn right and then they
started producing their own porn because
they're like we need to start changing
the way people like see sex Christian
porn no it's like it's like porn like
they still [ __ ] but then there's like
different emotions and sensitivity and
whatever yeah they try to change like
your perception of sex and porn and
relationships right all I did was
fast-forward through everything and go
straight to the [ __ ] part always
that's like what what Burt Reynolds
character was all about in Boogie Nights
but he's just filming wet [ __ ] you
know but they're always of like about Oh
something better like deeper love really
love and [ __ ] but it's always the same
thing I'm fast-forwarding that [ __ ]
submitted by I don't want it
I [ __ ] love when Nicki says that okay
a guy created his own pornhub channel
with hilariously wholesome content
really there you go
he's like just taking pie out of the
oven with handle with the oven mitts I
think it's Christian porn we're like the
girl like gives the guy a [ __ ] but
her hand is covering that dick the whole
time so technically you don't see it in
movies like we'd like she's thick the
girls going down someone's going down on
someone and then you just hear Oh true
the sound effects you never like now
you'll hear it but I hate every time I
know that's happening they tell me like
no no you have to play Game of Thrones
Lloris and like Renly Baratheon
I need to start watching it again before
season three baby fox
okay so this guy here his name is Ryan
creamer oh my god nice he's 26 years old
he's a comic and a writer for college
humor oh so he said that one time he was
just on pornhub I was just just on there
just on there okay and he scrolled all
the way to the bottom of one page we
just stolen a work for us option oh so
he clicked and he was like anyone could
get verified so he just went through the
process
he got an account I got his own channel
pretty much on pornhub on pornhub I was
like you to know you can do that yeah
yeah he reads the [ __ ] on us so you can
make money on pornhub I love that show I
know it says what's this one pornhub
okay I didn't know that you could make
your own channel important up I don't
know why I just thought like what I
don't even know where I thought those
videos came from are you thinking about
making the channel now Brenda BAM
wait is there adsense on it just like
you know that like ads for other sex my
mind is bullets are like MC ends for
these porn channels are good yeah we're
just different production crews like oh
these are the production this is the
company that does like the [ __ ] the
hard guys [ __ ] pen bros hot guys
[ __ ] hot she likes she likes gay porn
oh it's dude just [ __ ] each other
sometimes it's mostly threesomes okay
fine
oh whoa I never even thought of that
[Laughter]
Oh Devil's Triangle I think it's just
like so one dude is getting entered and
then the other dude behind him is also
probably getting enter they're all
entering each other but in a circle it's
called a conga line
stay connected down the guy in the
middle gets really inside of someone and
someone inside of him he's like really
catch it no one gets the most the guy in
the very front he's having the toughest
time for sure Wow no he's getting [ __ ]
but that's insane
at least probably five people no it's
not it's not awesome it's that he is
having the toughest time because the
most of our forces being rusty I want to
answer this question now how many guys
does it take to complete a full circle I
think you need like five people any more
than five yeah and it depends on how big
the guys are if everyone's like a
footlong no it's like it's like a god
like this it's like so do you think it'd
be more like 12 the inside we laying
down they all have to lay on their sides
and then it works they can't stand up
you have to it's like it's like who do
you spread a bunch of playing card job
oh yeah you have to go and fan it all
the way around a circle like a ninja
star of men and you just yeah there's
gonna be titled and a star of man
wholesome porn Jess wholesome porn Oh
awesome adult videos wholesome I don't
know a merry-go-round no matter what
really we're just gonna lose money on
this
I thought merry-go-round that's really
good friendship merry-go-round
yeah friendship marriage that's really
good
man I need a writers room for the titles
this is this okay anyway so it's a dick
to ask carousel okay so the story here
um so he created a channel on his first
upload was titled I tuck you in after
you come and it's funny is Ryan by the
way how does that remind me a barrage
eels relationship because I don't like
oh I want to be able to I want to I want
to be able to want to [ __ ] him so I
don't do the baby should I feel you I
want to be able to [ __ ] him again me too
doing feminine so Joe shaving your legs
alright I'll stop wearing your stockings
alright like I offer you water
parentheses in case you are parched post
orgasm and it literally him just talking
and like off like there's no space and
martyrs watch it can we watch it tonight
yeah I bet those people still bust into
his face though they're telling you
that's the truth should I ever heard
this other one I hug you and say I had a
really good time tonight and then I go
home oh my god the other one I your
stepbrother
decline your advances but I am flattered
nonetheless like they're all the genres
I did a dishes without being asked hey
hey in a taxi and don't have sex with
the driver oh my god pretty good
remember when I did that was that sexy
what when I wash the dishes without you
asking not really cuz you don't really
wash them that well then I kind of feel
like I need to go back in and oh no one
sent it for this man to DV do I do [ __ ]
I'd rather I'd rather do it myself you
should just throw all the trash but I
thought those plates guys POV forehead
kiss compilation oh my god did you watch
any of no I tuck you in after you have
come yeah hilarious he said that after
the first upload he didn't really have
any like plans or like any sort of like
an actual direction of what he was gonna
do he was just like I just knew that I
wanted to do this on the side so that's
cool cuz some people need to make post
[ __ ] videos cuz every time you're gonna
wash the dirty off of you a little bit
yeah Nikki needs a couple time no no she
needs the cuddle time yeah yeah like for
guys you know like sometimes there's
videos where after the guy nuts she goes
even harder what she'll [ __ ] bust but
Buster's not in her mouth it's go and
it's like Oh aren't you sensitive dude
and she'll suck it even more maybe
they're on viagra or something wait
what's the point of you saying that
because oh this one is soft but yes but
we need to post [ __ ] like oh nice post
card what happens after that's dramatic
yeah it's like a post [ __ ] relaxation
therapy poker that's like the press
conference after the fight after the I
don't want to talk about it so would you
why'd you punch him in the face yeah if
you think about it in movie terms right
like the [ __ ] the calm is the is the
[ __ ] ending of the big battle but
then what about the ending image what
about diamonds yeah what about that
where they wrap everything up and and
it's all cool ending credits yeah cuz I
want to know after they deliver that
pizza and [ __ ] what did they do did they
eat pizza after and talk
he never eat the pizza after he said you
should with his dick unless they should
have been supportive charity hundred his
dick everywhere on her whole body and
her mouth and inside him Nate the pizza
after his dick was he should be man
enough to eat that [ __ ] piece he just
stuck his tongue in their [ __ ]
[ __ ] the only time I get some type of
conclusion is if they do the woman one
of the bangbus and then afterwards they
drop her off and then she's like waiting
for the bus or something no no just drop
the [ __ ] throw money hit her face and
then they yeah at least I know what
happened
God the other ones are just it just cuts
that's it yeah you're always wondering
I'm like what's yeah what's next yeah
yeah so for Ryan here he's saying that
everyone who works in porn and sex
industry they have been so nice to him
so he was kind of worried about that cuz
it does kind of come off as if he's
making fun of like all these porn videos
and stuff but he was just saying like
yeah everyone's been so nice it's been
really really cool I'm just gonna keep
doing this you should go to like
whatever they're VidCon is like sex so
don't you should go tune and see what
doesn't mean everything looks like I saw
the billboard no we're going to it and
they have the AVN's to which is another
like almost like its own Oscars he did
the direction though whatever you
produce the thing there are your elation
things oh sorry the creative director
that's what it is thank you creative
director but anyway yeah this thing went
I got to watch it yeah I want to watch
it too his name is Ryan creamers I don't
know if that's how you couldn't you can
find y'all have fun googler that one
yeah switch on pornhub yeah lava blast
yeah it is it's it's porn hon
pornhub.com slash model slash Ryan cream
creamer and then hashtag exclamation
mark you know we could see oh my god can
we upload our YouTube videos on there oh
my god any girlfriend as she talks about
her day
evany girl he's doing the interracial
sex John run disinfect the casting couch
I owe you a pizza
don't put my wiener in it and give you
my jacket because you're cold yeah these
are funny dope
I blow you a platonic kiss 7 seconds 16
seconds oh my god he literally were like
this before watching that they're
probably cracking up yeah they're all
they're all in on the meme man there is
a lot of people commenting like hey what
a nice guy
well there's always gonna be it's just
like reddit this is the same five
comments it's like it's like this is my
best bap or whatever the [ __ ] you know
always what loser really logs into
pornhub in leaves comments though yeah a
special kind so the most viewed one he
has on his channel is 400 and 1,000
views 98% thumbs up 400,000 and it's the
I encourage you as you continue
searching for the right video - you know
he jacks off a lot to know these jokes
it's an insight it's true another job
absolutely not nope
I don't even know what this site is
let's go pornhub
hornpub oh yeah [ __ ] I've no idea I
have no clue
[Music]
[Music]